[Musique]
l'été sera
affecté des marques importées
[Musique]
bonjour 5view je vous salue de berkeley
en californie
[Musique]
je vois que en principe en théorie
l'amérique pense qu'elle a une économie
libre et qui a réglé par le marché
ouverte mais en vérité comme tout le
monde c'est
de le dollar est très faible parce que
l'amérique fait beaucoup plus
d'importation que de l'exportation et
ce système qui n est pas très
très solide ce que on a vu des crises
versement de surtemps
2007-2008 et danse crise oil les banques
non seulement des états unis mais les
banques mondiaux ont eu une crise manque
de capitaux qui a été soulevée par là
les fonds illégaux et les fonds noirs
comme on dit on devait
le trafic de drogue et on ne sait pas le
bon dieu le trafic de drogue mais on a
fait une estimation que peut-être
il
milliards de dollars en qui sont
blanchis dans les banques et il y a une
un officier des
nations unies qui a dit il y avait des
banques qui auraient échoué pendant
cette crise soit s'il n'y avait pas eu
cette
ré midi des défenses et légaux dans le
trafic de drogue
il ya deux façons de
le rôle de la guerre contre la drogue
pour moi le fait principal le plus
important c'est que le prix des drogues
est beaucoup plus élevé que ce qu'il y
aurait s'il n'y avait pas cette guerre
contre ça veut dire que les gros
roi de la drogue
il approuve cette guerre contre la
drogue passeur c'est la source le profit
et c'est la drogue devient quand même
une taxe
sur les gens ordinaires qui enrichit les
riches et ses fonds enfin il arrive dans
les banques américaines
les banques se font des arrangements
spécifiques pour recevoir ces fonds
privés ayant il ya la banque ordinaire
est pris à côté la banque privée qui
reçoit des fortunes illégales comme
celle par exemple du frère du président
faure président de mai du mexique
qu'elle est comme ça c'est
ça
le résultat c'est que la drogue est même
plus important dans l'économie qui se ne
serait signe où nous n'avions pas pas
cette guerre contre la drogue
oui c'est vrai que
pour
pour les états quand je parle par
exemple de la californie là notre
premier produit
agronome c'est le marijuana mais c'est
vrai qu'il n'ya pas une taxe sur la
marijuana parce que ce n'est pas légal
ça commence à changer un petit peu mais
en principe c'est illégal ce n'est pas
taxée et le gouvernement souffre
l'économie c'est différent parce que
même si nous parlons maintenant de
l'héroïne qui provient de l'afghanistan
les grands profits non ne sont pas faits
en afghanistan le club le pays de
production
ils sont dans le pays de consommation ou
parce que
on estime que peut-être 80 ou plus 80
personnes du profit est fait dans ces
pays là et même les autres
professions aussi banque est dans un
pays où les banques sont fermées
garantie c'est à dire les états unis
il ya eu deux moments où les états unis
se sont intervenus en afghanistan le
premier était contre les virus et
soviétique en
1979 et le deuxième évidemment après le
11 septembre 2001
le résultat de ces deux interventions
c'est que l'afghanistan qui a toujours
eu
de
l'opium et de haschisch de marijuana
mais avant la première américaine
de version américaine n'était pas une
puissance dans le marché international à
la consommation étaient locales et même
les amériques hérisson veut aller pour
avoir avoir
n'était de drogue sont
sans danger dans les années 70 c'était
ce qu'on appelle le pis tenir des piles
trio mai
de presque rien en
1979 jusqu'à maintenant maintenant c'est
presque 90 personnes de l'héroïne
internationaux provient de
l'afghanistan et même aux états unis si
je peux acheter une autre chiffre il y
avait le personnage de l'héroïne aux
états unis qui provenait de ce qu'on
appelle le croissant d'or 7 et 0 en
1979 et selon le gouvernement en
1996 sauter jusqu'à 60 personnes
[Musique]
on voit que washington et à ce grand
problème de la drogue et y aller
les sociologues des médecins toutes
sortes experts qui disent que yves et il
faut vraiment changer la loi et surtout
pour commencer légaliser la marijuana
mais c'est un sujet interdit à
washington personne c'est un buzz si on
veut poursuivre une carrière politique
il faut pas se mêler de ce problème et
elle a raison je pensais passer les
trolls trop d'argent le taux de profit
un qui provient de la situation actuelle
et ses poussins c'est une exemple pas le
seul où notre démocratie ne fonctionne
pas parce que les l'argent interdit la
discussion des vrais problèmes dont le
drogue est vraiment eu les grands
problèmes qui ruine
les
et la vie dans les grandes villes
ntt com nous disons en anglais et
pendant 50 ans on a attendu un
changement de des lois mais
c'est interdit comme sujet c'est est ce
que c'est parce que les politiciens sont
pas libres oui sont libres de discuter
s'ils veulent mais ils savent très bien
que ce sera la sphère de leur car leur
carrière alors pour ça ils ne discutent
pas
j'ai dans ma vie je n'ai passé que six
mois washington chacun se connaît
washington très mal mais j'ai vu une
exemple au congrès le
de la façon dont laquelle on n'est pas
permis de parler de la drogue je faisais
partie d'une commission secrète et ses
deux des neuf ans recevaient des
discours dans une chambre privée pour
une des commissions de la chambre
du congrès et
le président cette commission a dit au
commencement que ea humour qu'il voulait
pas absolument ne voulait pas entendre
non la discussion et 7 mo était l'idole
arracher l'égalisation
et je me suis demandé pourquoi
mais plus tard j'ai fait de recherche
j'ai trouvé que cette ce représentant de
la chambre avait un frère avec une aile
qu'est ce qu'on dit il et
il était avocat dans son bureau des
avocats et avait été un très grand
client c'était une des plus grands rois
de la drogue dans la ville de new york
alors c'était une source de profits
qui ont été abîmés ici la drogue avait
été légalisé et c'est pour ça je contre
cet individu béquille tessin individus
assez important d'ailleurs
qu'il voulait pas entendre le mot
l'égalisation
c'est vrai aussi il y a des grandes
bureaucraties comme le dit et le qui est
chargé d'empêcher la drogue et quand les
touts les prisons et toute cette
bureaucratie deviennent une partie du
système qui gouverne le pays veulent pas
voir un changement
c'était comme dans les années 20 aux
états unis avec la prohibition
que de plus en plus c'est évident qu'il
fallait changer mais avait à cette
époque aussi un grand résistant ce qui
provenait de la bureaucratie et ailleurs
quand enfin on a légalisé la corolle
c'est le moment où
on a haussé la poursuite des drogues et
les gens qui anciennement chercher de
les boîtes de la coupole maintenant ils
cherchent et le marijuana pour la
première fois c'était tout de suite
après le
la fin de la prohibition de l'alcool
j'ai une faiblesse c'est que j'invente
des mots de temps en temps comme la
politique profonde et aussi j'ai inventé
cette phrase soupre monde il ya en
anglais en dessous monde et qui fait
puissance sur le gouvernement dans ma
mais c'est beaucoup plus faible que les
puissances sur le gouvernement d'en haut
et j'appelle tous cette force privé la
décoration mais aussi des individus des
très riches
les très riches qui s'occupe de la
politique je lai je les appelle le sou
pro monde et dans mon bouquin
ici la route vers le désordre mondial
j'ai même donné une définition que je
vais lire et pour ça il me faudra me
l'une est une instance supra mende
le royaume de la société riche et
privilégiés qui est le théâtre d'une
influence efficace exercée sur
gouvernement par le pouvoir privé bien
que le supprimant 1 ne soit pas
institutionnaliser n'est autorisée
formellement exercer une telle influence
il a cru d'abord seul dans l' influence
s'exerce à travers leurs richesses
qu'elles soient administrés
personnellement au plus tard d'ici
nellement par le biais des fondations
exonérés d'impôts et les projets
qu'elles soutiennent et deuxièmement les
représentants des premiers ce terme doit
être distinguée de celui de fredrik
ljungberg les super riches
c'est à dire les soixante familles les
plus riches des etats-unis dont il a
prédit d'une manière erronée en 1967
dans son ouvrage sixty five disent
qu'elles continueraient à dominer les
états unis autant crasse et gouvernement
de l'argent les récents classement
annuel établi par la revue forbes des
400 étasunien les plus riches démontre
que l'une berg s'est trompé sur deux
plans les plus riches d'héritier du
ministre whissell 67 ne sont
majoritairement
pas les plus riches d'aujourd'hui et les
plus riches d'aujourd'hui ne sont pas
nécessairement ceux qui projettent leurs
richesses dans le pouvoir public
politique
par ailleurs le support monde n'est pas
une crasse mais une catégorie ça c'est
très important il faut pas penser que
cette classe et unifiée irish les riches
se connaissent
mais ils nagent ils n'agissent pas d'une
façon
solidaire
et erronée de concevoir
les règles institutionnelles l'influent
aux studios paramount elle quittait
exerçait à travers la société bilderberg
la commission trilatérale où le conseil
des relations étrangères
cependant il existe des cabas moins
connus habituellement ces crêtes qui
prospèrent au sein de ces milieux de
supra monde par exemple en france la
seule clopine et où le safari clame
c'est ma définition
c'est vrai qu'ils sont
organisée c'est vrai qu'il existe par
exemple d'abord chaque année il existe
société bilderberg il existe une
commission trilatérale elle le fait même
de toute cette organisation différente
indique que c'est une situation plutôt
pluraliste que unifiée met donc au
milieu il faut vraiment se rendre compte
que par exemple
pas tout le monde le sait mais c'est
vrai que en
1974 quoi le gouvernement
wilson nono de terre a été bouleversée a
mis à la porte et
aussi de gaulle à la fin de son pouvoir
avait des problèmes avec son service
d'intelligence
et nous avons appris plus tard qu'il
existait un cercle pinet qui prenait
qu'ils étaient fiers de la fête qu'il
avait pu élire madame nature en
angleterre et
alors il ya pas même au lieu des six
organisations mais même des puissances
profonde au milieu de ce support au
monde parce que la france l'argent c'est
très très fort par exemple
nous savons très bien qu'il ya eu plus
de haussements de tarifs pour le pétrole
la première 1072
1972 13 et le deuxième en
1979 80
nous savons que nixon était responsable
pour le premier parce que ça a aidé ses
projets
pour régler
la région du golfe
et régnait ce qu'on dit la golf en tout
seul parce que les profits pour l'iran
l'arabie saoudite qui provenait du
rehaussement du pétrole payer pour leurs
importations des armes américaines avec
les équipes pour
pourrait enseigner l'emploi de ces armes
et tout ça le deuxième est évidemment
sous la présidence du président une
carte ce n'était pas ça n'est déjà pas
du tout sa politique au contraire
c'était un responsable pour sa chute
mais je crois que les républicains y
avait des contacts dans les pays
pétroliers et peut-être pipi en
particulier ont
encouragé opecst de hausser
le prix du pétrole est passé façon on a
vu l'élection presque simultanée de
nature en angleterre et puis aussi
réguler aux états unis est vraiment
l'élection du président afghan
était le début d'une nouvelle époque aux
états unis où il ya eu une grand
doucement de sa subvention pour les des
budgets militaires et pour les budgets
sucre et de cia cia commencer une guerre
en afghanistan et tout ça et on voit le
résultat dans
la société civile que avant 1980 les
cras riches et pauvres s'approchait dont
le revenu y avait une diminution de la
disparité entre les riches et les
pauvres mais depuis cette année là
depuis
1981 c'est le contraire que maintenant
les riches deviennent beaucoup plus
riches et les pauvres beaucoup plus
pauvres et nous sommes pires maintenant
que l'europe dans cette
salle ce statistiques c'est-à-dire avant
avant 1940 80 1 l'angleterre était un
pays de classe avec des riches et des
pauvres et les états-unis - maintenant
c'est le contraire
l'amérique est plus divisée entre les
riches et les pauvres que l'angleterre
ou presque n'importe quel autre pays
sauf la russie
quand je parle la supprimant 2
et que la super monde est divisé par une
grande
grande force
du gouvernement non c'est la source des
gens c'est surtout dans le passé les
gens entrer deux du supplément de son
entrée dans le gouvernement et surtout
au poste
je sais que ces critères de finances sur
ça que tu as dû
trésorerie incendie à mes os il ya eu
une institution au milieu du
gouvernement qui était qui recevait
beaucoup plus les la pensée les dérives
direction de world suite que le reste du
gouvernement
et c'était le cia cia et le cia qu'on a
été créé c'était vraiment une création
de wall street ne trouble était le
président il n'était pas très à l'aise
avec cette idée d'avoir un service
d'intelligence dans des conditions de
paix mais s'était ensuite qui a insisté
c'est lui qui a gagné
et c'est très intéressant de voir que
trop insister que chef dans son époque
le chef n'était jamais doit ensuite
toujours d'une amérique centrale
ce surtout de l'armée
avant 1
evènement ce furent
il n'y avait jamais
chef qui provenait du ou ensuite mais
les sous-chefs tous les sous chefs que
nous connaissons 7 je connaissais ils
étaient tous de wall street et en plus
il ya ce qu'on appelle la société juste
et ça veut dire
le des gens de richesse hérité la grande
société du new york cistes ce set était
de cette société ce sochaux registers
alors dès le commencement
c'était une création de wall street et
enfin
pour des raisons techniques dont je
parle dans mon book mont bouquet mercure
war machine ces titres qui a fait
introduire alan doss comme de ses sous
chef dans le cia mais le moment que les
républicains ont enfin gagné le
président sont 1952
c'était la fin des chefs de l'armée
sedee nobilo smith et ses commencements
de l'époque janos veres qui était aussi
à
nôtres dalo son frère qui était
secrétaire d'état et ça nous avons eu
vu à cette époque un politique pure de
wall street commençons avec
l'assistance pour soulever le président
ait lieu en iran monsieur mossadeq pour
sauver
la compagnie pétrolière 1-2 iranien qui
maintenant on s'appelle bp et
deuxièmement tout de suite après on
guatemala pour
sauver
united food contre
contre une autre président élu albert
est lui pas une façon démocratique
il faut sur la plaie que john hogg créer
un crayon
cette saillie est pensé que ce serait un
service d'intelligence de renseignement
de trouver des nouvelles de tous les
pays mais
dès le commencement
sous la direction des gens de wall
street ils sont entrés dans les
opérations c'est à dire des
opérations criminelles original dans le
reste du monde parce que et c'était à
cause en partie de menace soviétique à
l'époque la première opération c'était
de m argent de l'élection italienne de
1948 et on disait que les russes
faisaient la même chose alors il fait il
fallait faire une bonne chose mais dans
les années cinquante huit toutes les
opérations du cia des grosses opérations
il était pour le bien du ensuite et on
ne sait pas seul parce que
le cio est aussi se mêler dans le sud
est de l'asie
en commençant ce d'abord un thaïlandais
puis birmanie et puis le laos et enfin
d'une façon beaucoup plus grande vis
attenante
je dirais que dès le commencement à les
interventions du cio était pour les bus
défini par wall street d'abord c'est à
ce moment si nous parlons du conseil des
relations extérieures de canso
formulation qui avait eu discussion ce
qu'on devrait faire en guatemala avant
que le cia a commencé alors premièrement
discussions à new york décision est
prise de décision communiquée à
washington c'était sous eisenach qui
était très volontairement oui il était
d'accord mais la façon d'influencer la
politique c'était à trèves surtout à
travers le cio et ça a été exécuté par
le c1 et je vois la même chose plus tard
avec vietnam parce que un vietnam était
pour moi la vraie raison pour avoir un
devenu
en viennent au vietnam c'était à cause
que avec des développements techniques
de
recherche de pétrole pour la première
fois on pouvait trouver de puits de
pétrole au dessous de la mer et on
savait d'elle dès le commencement des
années 50 qu'il y avait beaucoup de will
do sul la mère chinoise la mer entre le
vietnam et l'indonésie
et nous voyons à cette époque des
grandes interventions décès au vietnam
et à l'indonésie
et après ça les
signatures des contrats avec les
compagnies américaines pour développer
l'huile sous la mer au vietnam au
cambodge
thaïlande et surtout à l'indonésie j'ai
eu des buts est vraiment dans mes
recherches en
cherchant la raison pour laquelle les
américains sont intervenus dans la
politique indonésienne en
1965 avec le résultat un grand massacre
2 pts millions de personnes personnes
civils femmes et enfants
célèbrent toute une classe des
institutions dans les écoles parce
qu'ils étaient dans une partie
communiste mais un parti communiste
assez pacifique qui comptait gagner une
élection ça c'était une une des grandes
interventions
des états unis non seulement le ca mais
aussi l'armée américaine avec
avec toutes sortes chose mais c'était
pour le pétrole
le reliquat à la fraude
ressources naturelles de la région on a
parlé de caoutchouc on a parlé d'eux
était un tout ça c'était pas faussé il
comptait surtout une des plus grands - -
discuter mais très important c'était le
veau femmes tout le système je ne
connais pas le bo française
j'espère que c'est winston c'est une
scène où l'anglais et c'est absolument
nécessaire pour à sciez fort pour les
armements dans les chars blindés et c
est absolument nécessaire et ça
provenait dans cette époque de lachine
québec est maintenant hors de question
et aussi de
la jce de sud est
ça c'était vrai aussi mais le pétrole a
dépassé je crains les autres surtout le
caoutchouc parce que maintenant la
plupart de notre caoutchouc ça provient
de la pétrole c'est artificiel et
et on voit voir dans les statistiques
la commerce entre l'asie du sud-est et
l'amérique était basée sur le pétrole
les investissements qu'on a vu dans
l'asie du sud est un grand parti parle
aussi du japon mais le japon aussi était
son économie après la guerre était une
création des américains
parce qu'on pense à cette époque
américaines étaient définis par la
guerre froide de tendre la russie
l'union soviétique on se demande
que
en quelle partie 7 cette guerre froide
était vrai et auquel partie c'était une
espèce de masques pour des raisons à
plus
capitaliste de wall street mon opinion
personnellement j'ai eu j'y réfléchis
beaucoup parce que j'étais je ne sais
pas cette époque mais je le rappelle le
bien c'est que en partie le père de
l'union soviétique était réel et
est vrai c'est à dire que
je crois pas jamais jamais l'union
soviétique aurait un vade l'europe de
l'ouest avec c
ces divisions en europe bionest et ça
c'est le grand mythe de l'otan et quand
j'étais au gouvernement j'ai commencé à
questionner ce mythe je ne croyais pas
cette époque que je ne le crois pas
maintenant mais je crois c'est très très
possible que les partis communistes en
italie et en france or gagner leur
élection et c'est parce que le sénat est
un devenu pour
empêcher ce résultat que nous voyons
maintenant
une europe non communiste est de mon
point de vue personnel je n'aime pas les
moyens
qui ont été
utilisées pour protéger l'europe de
l'ouest mais je suis très content que ne
voyons pas
une france qui a subi la même politique
après la guerre que par exemple la
pologne parce que j'ai vécu en pologne
c'était pas si pire j'ai je connaissais
les gens dont le gouvernement socialiste
ils étaient mes copains mais
c'est cette triste pour la pologne et je
suis content que les pologne mais
maintenant libre de l'influencé russe et
pour moi personnellement je crois que
les événements en france aurait été
aussi triste si l'ego les communistes
étaient mises au pouvoir sont des sujets
qui sont très difficiles à discuter mais
j'ai dit tout ça pourrait mettre qui
avait une élément de vérité
au commencement dans ma vie guerre
froide mais aussi il faut voir que quand
cette guerre s'est développée ça a été
de plus en plus influencée par
les intérêts privés du suprêmement des
gg je vais inclure maintenant osciller
grande coopération internationale de
l'époque il était surtout les les
corporations du pétrole comme ceinture
d'orion ex ce que nous appelons
maintenant
exxonmobil taxco
c'est la guerre froide s'est changé
pendant des années pour devenir une
façon pour protéger des intérêts de ces
grandes corporations
n'ont passé la saison morte mais en
partie en europe avec le truman doctrine
abu
garantir une grèce non communiste
c'était un ami à la au moins à cette
époque que cette est admis que c'était
pour garantir que le pétrole de l'arabie
saoudite pour être pourrait être vendue
en europe parce que le mot les grandes
campagnes corporation ne voulais pas que
ça provienne aux états unis parce qu'ils
avaient encore une production domestique
ici aux jeunes il il fallait que ce
pétrole aïe aïe europe et pour ça il
fallait voir une grèce donc communiste
ça c'était une commencement de
mélange entre la vraie guerre froide et
les interventions de la corporation mais
plus tard c'est presque purement les
compensations
oui je viens d'écrire un petit article
sur la situation actuelle au milieu de
2013 en syrie parce que c'est un choix
qui s'est reproduit maintes fois dans
l'histoire américaine
soit entre une politique militaire et
politique diplomatique
c'était au commencement du mois de mai
que
les états unis
et la russie se sont accordés qu'il
fallait
contenir une convention peut-être genève
pour chercher une solution
internationale
diplomatique au problème
sérieux qui devenait de plus en plus
grave et qui menace est de plus en plus
de grandir et de sentir au delà des
frontières syrienne est de créer une
crise
au liban en irak et même peut-être en
turquie
parce qu'il ya des kurdes partout et
j'étais très déçu que enfin obama qui
est depuis une position très eux
les crises il ne voulait pas se mêler
dans cette ferme est enfin sous la
pression des faux quand
à washington et ont
accordé leur envoyer des armes des
petites sommes mais des arbres
au combattons et 7e places une blague
parce que déjà le cia y avait envoyé non
pas seulement des armes mais aussi des
les spécialistes pour enseigner dans les
âmes c'est un peu comme la libye avait
une politique secret qui déjà
commencé cette politique ça c'est très
dangereux pour une solution diplomatique
internationale
l'espoir n'est pas tout à fait éteint
mais c'est beaucoup plus faible
maintenant le problème c'est que dans
syrie comme dans les autres pays de
galles dont j'ai parlé et un problème de
pétrole la liesse maintenant c'est plus
sain plus le gaz avant c'était lui le
pétrole maintenant c'est de plus en plus
le gaz on a découvert du gaz même en
syrie mais ce qui est beaucoup plus
important c'est de
[Musique]
ramener un gaz fils de champ de gaz de
cette région
de gaz sous terre ce sous la golf qui
partager un boîtier pour le qatar 1
moitié pour l'iran et c'est le sait la
région les plus grandes donc tout le
monde le marché pour se garer sur un
lieu en europe et
a conduit le gaz ne passeront pas par
israël ils passeront par la syrie comme
d'habitude il y avait eu le premier
conduit de pétrole est une base de
l'arabie saoudite
passé par l'irak et enfin de syrie à la
méditerranée ça a été terminé il ya
longtemps il y avait une autre conduit
qui était abîmée pendant la guerre
d'irak
mais maintenant c'est un choix
alcatel a dit
monsieur assad en syrie il faut que vous
vous démissionnez nous voulons un
gouvernement
plus musulmane qui ne laisserait notre
conduite de gaz de passer de l'irak à
turquie parce qu'il ya maintenant une
grande conduit 2 gaz qu'on va construire
la ligne nabucco en turquie et qatar
voulait vendre son regard cette ligne
mais
à la fois sa semoule à nemo l'iran a dit
nouveau aussi proche de gaz de cette
même région et de l'envoyer en europe
par une conduite qui passeraient iran
et
irak parce que maintenant d'irak est
beaucoup plus proche alliant corps et 9
ans et enfin syrie et
cette guerre entre le gouvernement d'un
côté et les différents partis deux
hommes entre les rebelles
et son réseau et ses subventionné
surtout par le qatar qui ont mis le club
des jeunes
pays je crois plus de 3 milliards de
dollars de subventions pour cette
révolte parce qu'il veut la voir
assad à la porte 1 pour avoir leurs 38
mais assad est protégé maintenant ils
commencent à gagner avec l'appui du
hezbollah qui est directement
subventionné en partie dirigées de
terrain en irlande et assad a signé un
contrat officiel avec l'iran pour avoir
un collier de gaz qu'il passerait
directement on appelle ça je crois le
le conduit de gaz islamique
qui est pas cela de
de l'iran
a maintenant une porte et anciennement
était en progrès c'est petit mais qui
deviendra assurément beaucoup plus gros
à cause de gaz même là bas même en syrie
même est sûre c'est comme le groupe la
grande partie des interventions de
l'amérique et de série n importe où et
surtout en libye et en irak il
s'agissait du pétrole du gaz et la série
n'est pas une exception
mais si le plus tôt il s'était comme
l'afghanistan même parce que le moment
où
les états unis commençaient à
s'intéresser la fin des avec le taliban
et enfin la fin des années 1980 il y
avait 1 on parlait de conduire de
pétrole qui qui passerait de kazakhstan
à pakistan à travers l'afghanistan
c'est pour ça le local compagnie
américaine inviter des gens les 80 ans
de talibans de venir à texas pour être
enseignée les affaires techniques
c'est toujours le pétrole corrige quand
on parle de l'amérique ils sont
pétrodollars qui est les bases sa
fortune internationale
l'amérique
est divisé entre des faucons et les
colombes sur le théme adieu syrie et
en europe c'est le même situation même
on pourrait la division encore plus
grave parce qu'il ya deux sortes de des
intérêts en europe des petits pays comme
l'autriche à l'est qu'elles veulent
avoir
de gaz aussitôt que possible et ils
veulent pas être sous
l' influence trop profond de dollars
russie alors ils invitent 7 la france au
contraire
qu'ils avaient des intérêts historiques
dans la région et
l'autriche est peut-être une des
colombes de l'europe et la france
actuellement eu des faucons du europe
quelle qu'elles étaient aussi dans la
cadre la libye c'était bernard lévy qui
a dans ce sens débuté tous les problèmes
heureux au libye en
2010-2011 un sobre c'est pour ça que
c'est son problème de de gaz et de
pétrole ne sont pas simples il crée des
tpe des alliances régionales
et surtout aussi la russie
d'imposition assez compliqué à travers
ce conduit de pétrole parce que je
n'imagine que la russie préféré d'avoir
ni le
conduit 2 qatar ni le conduit de
l'hérault parce que le marché de pour le
gaz et fif et n'est pas infini est
limité et actuellement c'est une seule
gaz russe
pour terminer je voudrais
dire quelque chose à la jeunesse qui
insiste cette interview
vous de parler la raison pour laquelle
je fais mes recherches j'ai fait mes
enquêtes d'abord
je viens du canada qui pays aseptique si
on parle du nombre des gens et nous
avons au canada
l'impression que si nous avons une idée
pour améliorer le pays nous pouvons le
partager avec les dirigeants à trois
avec les membres du parlement canadien
et même en vérité je les fais un petit
peu quand j'étais jeune même avant l'âge
de 20 ans
et comme je suis arrivé aux etats-unis
j'avais la même illusion mais vous savez
très bien que c'est pas la même chose
aux états unis
et il ya plus de gens californie seul je
crois que au dans tout le canada alors
c'est un échelle tout à fait différente
et je dois dire que
si j'avais l'idée au commencement je lui
tiens contre l'intervention dans la
guerre du vietnam
de ma carrière dans la diplomatie je
connaissais un tout petit peu de la
situation vietnamiens pas beaucoup mais
à ces mots pour me convaincre que les
états unis ne devraient pas entrer dans
cette guerre pour pour la santé
américaine aussi à autant que la santé
venus vietnamienne et j'ai bien appris
que tout mouvement des milliers des
milliers parce que du million vrai à la
fin ils ont assisté une tout petit peu à
terminer cette guerre mes mots
ma contribution
personnelle était très très petit et je
n'ai pas même l'impression que mes idées
vont changer les états unis pas du tout
mais quand même je suis très content de
faire ce que je fais je je rencontre des
gens que j'adore comme déjà je suis dans
une sombre ici avec du copain que j'ai
rencontré dans un mouvement et dans ses
mouvements
je regarde les gens que j'aime et aussi
j'ai toujours lydec même si j'ai
construite contribue pas aux politiques
de dupes raison qu'il ya toujours la
politique de l'avenir et que peut-être
je peux persuadé d autres gens d'être le
cas moi
intéressé dans la justice internationale
de la liberté personnelle et dans la
démocratie
c'est un
sur l'écran du niveau de washington
c'est un très mauvais mouvement
mouvement très mauvais moment maintenant
pour la justice la liberté à la
démocratie
mais quand même je vois que les
le mauvaise politique de washington
créer une opposition et je veux
absolument je veux être partie de cette
opposition parce que j'ai la foi dans la
race humaine
que nous avons une tendance enfin vers
la démocratie vers la liberté et
dieu la joie d'être
libres 2 c'est une société libre et
ouverte et je suis très déçu si je ne
pensais pas que je pourrai contribuer
tout petit peu à cet avenir et je veux
j'espère que parmi vous autres vous
ouvre la jeunesse
lui aurait des gens qui vont avoir la
même espoir de participer dans l'avenir
de notre pays de notre globe
et notre race humaine merci beaucoup
il ya actuellement un site us
les pas prévues il y avait un temps on
fait des comparaisons entre les états
unis avec leur surveillance
universel et
l'allemagne de l'est à l'époque tu stasi
où il y avait la même chose et c'est une
des grandes indications que depuis le 11
septembre
nous avons vraiment vu un gros
changement aux états unis on n'aurait
pas prévu cette surveillance universel
et ça c'était une résultat de ce qu'on
appelle le
contenu du monde
le sait aux jets continus et et de
gouvernement qui avait été planifié
planifié pendant 20 ans par un
groupement des gens partent en partie
ans dans le gouvernement est en partie
dehors le plus intéressant c'est que 12
de ces gens qui ont planifié étaient
dans leur robe verte et le turc génie
qui était au pouvoir à washington le 11
septembre le président bush était en
floride
et c'est josé deux jours là ils ont fait
commencé à implémenter les provisions
provision de contenu adulte
et
on peut les résumer en trois catégories
d'abord surveillance universel son
mandat de d'une cour et deuxièmement
qu'il était beaucoup plus pire je crois
détention indéfinie sans son mandat d'un
cours et 3e au
l'intervention
permanent du de l'armée des militaires
dont la sécurité domestique
des états unis les points 2 et 3 étaient
contre les l'oise existence même on
pourrait dire qu'on sur la constitution
des états unis
vraiment
il faut expliquer aux
instances françaises que l'idée
de détention son mandat indéfini ça
quand tu reviens une des libertés les
plus profondes et les plus
traditionnels de la tradition anglo
saxonne sade ça a été donné par le
magnat cartin dans la neige ou 115 et
depuis ce temps là nous avons eu ce
qu'on appelle et
bassecourt
si quelqu'un est détenu dans 24 48
heures mais mais bientôt il faut
produire ce le type qui a été détenu et
bien que je crois que c'est horrible que
nous avons maintenant une surveillance
universel
pour trouver des terroristes on a trouvé
peut-être 21 50 ça dépend de votre
définition mais moins 2 sur 7 fatalement
moins de 500 terroristes aux etats-unis
1-1 se vêtent tout le monde est
permanemment tout le temps et ça est
devenue une excuse pour contrôler le
public en général
pour créer une situation très très
similaire que ce que le romancier
giorgio a prévenu dans son roman
1994 et s'est trompé de date mais il a
vraiment prévenu ce que nous avons
maintenant aux états unis est aussi le
troisième point
l'intervention des militaires
d'une façon permanente
dans la sécurité domestique et a oscillé
loi
spécifiquement américaine que penser
comme et à tous lowe's qui est interdit
cela et ça tout un sèche tout a changé
pareillement pour toujours à 10 heures
le matin du 11 septembre
cantini et ramsgate ont fait implémenter
les provisions de
conteneurs était avocat me manque le
résultat c'est que nous avons
l'état public qui continue comme opera
ou au bar avant mais nous avons
maintenant un deuxième et un état secret
ou en commun on commence à dire de plus
en plus une étape profonde qui n'est pas
gouvernée par le cour
suprême qui fait ses propres lois
ya maintenant deux des questions très
techniques où je vais pas
entrer dans ces problèmes dans ce
discours mais c'est pas seulement moi
même qui parle d'un état profond
maintenant aux états unis et même des
gens
des des
académiciens qui parle qu'il ya eu une
coup un coup d'état
le 11 septembre parce que c'est un tel
changement de la condition politique du
pays c'est vrai qu'il faut faire des
jeux reconnaître des similitudes avec la
situation de l'allemagne de l'est et
pour une pays comme l'amérique qui était
qualité
qui est né dans des conditions de
révolution contre un gouvernement et
absolutiste
londres qui n'écoutaient pas les
intérêts locaux c'est vrai c'est
vraiment dramatique de voir le
changement qu'on a vu dans ce pays
c'est juste triste
mais c'est triste
mais
il faut pas penser que le public est
morte qui est là public oubliez l'idée
de la liberté
c'est très difficile de généraliser aux
de la condition des états unis et le
moment qu'en pense qu'on ne comprend ce
qui se passe aux etats-unis sur le
moment que nouveau mouvement qu'avait
ailleurs quand on n'attendait pas et
c'est pour ça que je n'ai aucune fois
que le gouvernement va corriger la
candidate des conditions actuellement
actuelle mais j'ai vraiment confiance
qu'il y aurait enfin un changement qui
proviendra du public des gens comme moi
et mes copains dans le mouvement
anti guerre
[Musique]
des types comme cahuzac qui en a pas il
n'a pas beaucoup c'est ss d'aplomb
incroyable avec lequel les les yeux dans
les yeux de tout le monde il a dit je ne
mens pas vous pouvez me croire et cetera
il y avait un truc peut-on imaginer que
nos politiciens on va être en mesure de
se dire non d'emblée l'intérêt général
c'est la défense des libertés
fondamentales liberté fondamentale c'est
la défense de la vie privée et là il ya
un conflit
c'est impossible d'appeler les hackers
en france le problème c'est que le moins
à coeur et est diabolisé on oublie
simplement tous sont des gens qui
privilégie les résultats sur les
méthodes et kif sont capables de gagner
une connaissance intime d'un système